I've got what is genuinely good news
about net neutrality if not monumental
news which is that at the state level
Washington State has approved their own
net neutrality requirements which sounds
really great and it's good but I don't
want to pretend like this is some
panacea Washington's the first state to
actually enact net neutrality
requirements since the FCC repealed the
Obama era net neutrality regulations
many states are discussing them some
states have done executive orders I
believe Oregon has agreed to some laws
but have have not yet enacted them so
what this will do is it will stop any
state agencies in Washington state from
doing business with ISPs that block
prioritize or throttle particular
internet content or apps and it'll also
force ISPs operating in Washington to
disclose the management practices that
they're employing there what this does
not do is mandate that ISPs at large
can't throttle or prioritize Internet
traffic or content that really would be
the big thing right but listen it's
something and there are lots of states
looking at doing similar things and we
should be honestly at this point glad
for anything that can be done other
states that are looking at similar rules
include Hawaii New Jersey New York
Montana and Vermont but I think that
there's actually sort of a bigger fish
to fry here
we often talk on this program about when
does the free market work and when
doesn't the free market work and when it
comes to something like healthcare I've
said it should not be in the so-called
free or open market we should eliminate
the profit motive from providing health
care to people because the demand for
health care is completely inelastic and
it just simply should not be operating
under a free market when it comes to
Internet service providers though part
of the problem is and part of why
Internet service providers treat
customers so terribly and regularly are
the most hated companies nationally is
that they offer terrible service at a
high price because there is no
competition or almost no competition and
if states instead of passing executive
orders that just say we will only deal
with
isps as a customer as a state customer
that don't do this or don't do that if
instead they tried to deal with the fact
that we have almost no legislation to
prevent these two facto monopolies that
exist in most places around the country
you would very quickly see that the need
for net neutrality rules goes way down
I'm not saying that if we did the
dealing of with the monopolies we can
just forget about net neutrality I think
we should have both but if you actually
get these ISPs competing you were going
to have a drastically different
situation not going to happen anytime
soon these are deliberately constructed
monopolies by design and that's because
an isp will come in and I admit there's
a lot of spending that has to be done to
establish the infrastructure for
high-speed internet and cable in a city
but the ISP will come in and I'll say
well we will set up shop in your city
town municipality whatever but you need
to commit to only doing business with us
and it's a real problem for bigger
cities we've seen small places there's
hill towns out in western Massachusetts
that have done this I think Leverett and
shoots Barry who are small enough that
they can do municipal broadband but that
is not the majority of places a lot of
cities especially cities that
financially are not doing well just
can't afford to do that and that's
something that needs to be dealt with
Google Fiber can can sort of help to
deal with it although development has
really slowed down maybe something like
Elon Musk satellite internet could help
but the states are gonna need to deal
with that the cities maybe if we really
want to have a shot at fixing this thing
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today I'm out of time but trust me it's
a good one no voice mail today either
because I was ranting about net
neutrality and monopolies we've got a
great bonus show for you and we'll talk
to you on the program tomorrow as well